Other things.
That's the football thing is an interesting thing cause he was who's obsessed
with football and it's one thing that he shared in common with Nixon.
And so when they went one time they were going to the airport and he hitched a
ride with Nixon and Nixon wanted to talk to him about football.
And he said,
let's just not talk about politics when we talk about football.
And so he talked to my favorite,
the whole ride.
It was,
it was in 1968 Pat Buchanan had helped set it up.
They handed out that week they'd become friends.
And so they come to Thompson and like,
all right,
the boss is going to take a plane to Florida.
You can come and talk to him and crazy.
And so later Thompson said later,
it was like,
they told me not to talk about anything but football.
But earlier Thompson said like,
I was just really awkward.
Like this fucking guy.
They're both in the back bench of a mercury and so as before secret service.
So it's just a cop driving and it's like pappy cannon in the front and it's
Thompson.
And Nixon and they're right here next to each other.
And Thompson's like wedge,
you know,
earlier in the night you'd said that,
the Oakland Raiders had a good shot to beat the packers and Superbowl too.
Can you talk about that?
And he was like,
Dick's is like my good friend Vince Lombardi had told me to watch out for the
AFL cause they pass and they can be very effective.
And so Thompson then like remembers that guy.
Um,
um,
Bob Geiger had been a professional quarterback.
He had taken Thompson to his first football game and Thompson said NFL is better
than the AFL and Geiger's like,
shut the fuck up,
let's go to a Raiders game.
And they went and 65 and the Raiders won on this beautiful pass,
uh,
Tom Flores,
like beautiful goline pass.
And Nixon was saying the same thing.
And so then at that moment,
at that moment,
Thompson's like,
oh yeah,
it was the Miami Guy,
uh,
Miller Miller who'd caught the pass in Nixon,
Gus taps and on the knee and goes,
you're right.
And goes all,
what a beautiful moment in tops.
It's just like,
what the fuck is going on?
So Nixon,
apparently they were talking about like college draft picks and all kinds of
crazy shit.
Like Nixon was deep into it.
It was the only moment Thompson said that he knew Nixon wasn't lying.
They can talk about football and that in that instance,
it's fascinating when people,
they're so diametrically opposed to each other,
but they find common ground.
Thompson did a great job of that,
and I think we've lost it today.
I mean,
you have to listen to the other side too.
If you,
if you politically want to beat somebody like pappy cannon,
the one,
it defeat his tactics.
If you wanted to feed him,
you need to know how he's thinking and what he's doing.
And Thompson knew that Bikini was listening to the left to defeat them.
And so Thompson listened to be Keenan.